good morning John do you ever worry that
all of the wonderful things that occupy
the space and our lives are built on a
human suffering and misery so a couple
of weeks ago Katherine and I were on a
little mini vacation at a hot spring in
Jackson Montana very small town just the
hot spring pretty much that's all that's
there we were on our way home and we
noticed a big sign for a thing and we
were like well we got a whole day to
drive home let's look at the thing hair
looks extremely good today I want my
hair to look like this forever look like
Topher brink from from the dollhouse
that's what a horrible nerdy thing to
want to look like my goodness anyway we
saw the sign we wanted to stop and that
is how I learned about the nez perce for
the last of the indian wars in America
I've never had a particularly good
conception of what Native Americans were
like in the 1800s in the West there's
sort of two prevailing views there's the
cowboys and Indians one where we're
shooting each other and then there's the
new agey in touch with the earth
seventh-generation use all of the
Buffalo nomadic wanderer ID and they're
probably elements of truth and both of
those but what I would not have thought
is that Native Americans in the West and
the 1800s were both powerful and rich
I'm not talking about wisdom and
spirituality I'm talking about
militarily powerful and economically
rich in fact they were much better
fighters than the American cavalry and
the numbers in these battles reflect
that they were far more American cavalry
members who died the Native American
what the Nez Perce Indians did
economically was really remarkable the
50 years between when white settlers
started showing up and this last Indian
war Nez Perce were able to use the
reasons they had that their disposal
their land and their knowledge of their
land in combination with entirely new
technologies like horses and guns and
carve out an extremely valuable and
unique niche in the American economy
which was making really great horses for
the American West that wasn't all that
they did but that's sort of what they
were famous for and it made a lot of Nez
Perce very wealthy and it made a lot of
Nez Perce tribes very powerful so let's
go real quick to the board the board is
something that I'm experimenting with
the bow on so I just wanted to give you
an idea of what caused the Nez Perce war
this is the original home line of the
Nez Perce and then this was the original
treaty that the United States government
had with the Nez Perce this was their a
greet upon homeland however the fact of
this area contains lots of good cattle
rain
and later they discovered actually lots
of gold became very problematic so
partially because the United States
feared letting the nez perce get their
hands on this gold and continuing to
have this extremely valuable resource in
the form of land the United States
compelled by force the Nez Perce to sign
another treaty that gave them this land
obviously not a good deal and many of
the Nez Perce tribes decided not to sign
that treaty these are the tribes that we
ended up going to war with this is where
Katherine and I were that day side of
the battle the big hole in the beautiful
big hole valley where the Nez Perce were
ambushed they had no idea that this
force was after them they were attacked
during the night the vast majority of
losses were women and children and the
elderly stuck in their TVs as general
Gibbons force moved through their camp
to me of course hundreds of years later
this does not look like a battlefield it
just looks like a beautiful valley
seemed kind of obsessed with remembering
the places where we lost battles but I
think it's probably more important
actually for the future of our culture
and even maybe our species that we
remember the places where we lost
something more than that
like for example our humanity and our
ability to tell when we're doing
something wrong in this valley a nation
of strong and wise people lost their
lives their families their possessions
their homes everything that they owned
they lost those things too to greed to
complacency to prejudice and they lost
those things not because they were weak
but because they were strong that's
something that I think is worth
remembering every once in a while John
I'll see you on Friday
you